so megan who are all these people
this is the peachy squad megan someone
says
oh my gosh this is my biggest dream
where's megan your fans are like going
nuts right now
roblox you've heard the name before it
is a great day for roblox for roadblocks
roadblocks
roadblocks the gaming platform became a
cultural icon during the pandemic
as kids gravitated to virtual worlds to
hang out with their friends
host birthday parties and even attend
concerts
daily active users skyrocketed 85
in 2020 making the company one of the
most valuable to go public during the
pandemic
but also making dozens of young roblox
developers
virtual celebrities and millionaires
one of them is megan letter aka megan
plays
[Music]
hey thanks for joining us today
yes thank you so much for having me tell
us about you
when did you first get interested in
gaming i've been interested in gaming
since i was literally two
from barbie games to nintendo in 2013
when i went into college i started my
very first gaming channel
hi guys my name is megan welcome to my
channel
and eventually it just evolved and now
i'm here playing roblox
so i created a little avatar for myself
she's very cute
so where are we we're in your house um
which is
pretty empty right now because you just
logged on for the very first time
but we could decorate it later so you
said you and your team created this
whole
overlooked bay it's all from scratch
it's all built from the ground up
um every model every soundtrack
every little piece of code for people
who don't
know can you just describe what roblox
is anybody can create games on roblox
realistically it's a game hub
of a bunch of different games created by
a bunch of different developers
hey what is up you guys it's megan
welcome back to my channel pt squad
today i am so excited because overlook
bay is finally free to the public
we wanted to create um our very own role
play experience a role-playing game is
essentially a game
that allows you to use your imagination
to create story lines you can go fishing
in our game you can go mining you can
raise a pet
and you can also play with others
so megan who are all these people oh you
have fans oh they're jumping
this is the peachy squad um they're very
great and lovely but a little
overwhelming at times
as you could probably tell oh my gosh
someone just said you are my idol
that's so sweet you're like it's just
another day
[Music]
and you mentioned a lot of your
followers are young girls a lot of the
people who are playing roblox
are young girls why do you think that is
i think my game specifically just has a
more female oriented demographic because
of
the nature of the game but i do think a
younger generation is drawn to roblox
because it's very accessible you can
play on your phone you can play on your
tablet it's an
online experience so you can make
friends
the features on overlook bay alone
earned megan a seven-figure take-home
salary in 2020
grossing over 1.5 million dollars in
four short months
before roblox took its cut and that
doesn't even include revenue from her
merch
and from youtube megan sees even more
growth for her brand
in 2021. how does roblox make money um
with robux
robux is an in-game currency so you can
use robux
on any game that you play what would i
spend money on in
overlook right now you could buy pet
pods you could buy exclusive pets you
could buy
vehicles anything like that to enhance
your game experience
then we can take those robux and cash
them out for cash
kids these days i mean back in the day
they wanted to be teachers and
astronauts but now kids want to be
youtubers and influencers what is that
like for you
to have that job that so many people
want
it's amazing what i do people aspire to
want to be
of course the world is always going to
need more doctors and teachers and i
super encourage people to do that
but what i think is really great about
my job is it's a creative outlet like i
feel free i could definitely consider
myself one of the lucky ones
do you feel like it's difficult to be on
as a developer all the time
running all these channels what's the
most stressful part about it
feeling like you're on a pedestal and
you don't want to let people down but
they can use four million followers
like sometimes these kids they comment
like that some of my videos are just
making their days better
and so if i can't post a video a day
that really tears me up
how would you advise somebody who wants
to do what you're doing and i'm not just
talking about being a personality on
youtube i'm talking about
developing and creating this universe
that you've helped
create find out what you want to do find
out if you like to draw or find out if
you like to do math equations
and use that to kind of get a hint for
who you are
and how you want to create
and megan you very much have a brand do
you have a very consistent bubbly
personality
was that just instant is that just megan
letter in high school i was pretty like
down on myself all the time didn't have
a lot of confidence didn't have a lot of
friends growing up either so i just
always have had this mentality of treat
others like how you want to be treated
so i always always always
try to remind my audience to like stay
peachy stay kind
and they really keep me going every day
so i think my audience is the reason
that i am so bubbly and happy
you're doing really great this is fun i
think i still have a lot to learn though
but yeah well you did really great for
your first time
what does the future look like we only
see things going up from here once you
hit the ground running and you kind of
know what you're doing and you have all
these systems in place for your games
you can only make more games you know
and we want to create so many things
we want to take so many things from our
imagination and bring them to life
i just think the future possibilities
are endless
[Music]
thanks for watching for more videos like
this you can stream bloomberg quick take
for free
24 7 in any of the places below get live
news coverage
interviews deep dives shows and
documentaries on the stories you care
about most
and be sure to follow us or subscribe to
us on twitter youtube instagram
and facebook